Now, if we're looking
back at our mock here,
we're going to start saying, well there
are some things that aren't the same.
Bootstrap isn't making, using this nice
font here, there's not light gray.
What we've done so
far is we've gone thru and
we've done what Bootstrap
can do natively.
Now what we're going to do is we're
going to apply our own styles on top of
that and
make the page look a little nicer.
Okay, so one of the first things
that we'll notice is that the font
that we have in the mock here is not
the same as the font that we're getting
sort of by default.
One of the great things that
Google provides is Google Fonts.
So I've found a font that is similar
to the one that we have in the mock.
It's not perfect, but it'll do.
And what we're going to do
is we're going to select,
we have a very thin version of
it up here in the name, and
a sort of thicker, higher weight
version of it in the rest of the page.
So what we need is two font weights.
Font weights are how thick or
thin a font is.
And for this project,
I'm going to be using the Thin and
the Light for
those two situations I just pointed out.
Google Fonts may look slightly
different when you use it.
They change it from time to time.
But the general concept is you're
going to select your font.
In this case, I've picked Lato.
And we're going to then select
what weight we want to use.
The characters, in this case we're just
gong to use the Latin character set.
Use the Latin Extended if you need
accents and things like that,
that aren't in the normal Latin set.
And, we come down here and Google
has provided us with a handy little
piece of HTML that will link this font
with these weights into our page.
So we go back and we're going to
put that up in the head and
that will make sure that we have
that font loaded and ready to go.
But just loading it into the page
isn't going to do anything.
We actually have to make
a style that can use it and
it tells our page to use it.
So what we're going to do next is
we're basically just going to make
a styles.css and this will contain
all of our personal styles.
So we've used Bootstrap styles already.
And we'll make our own styles.css.
So, in the same way that
we loaded Bootstrap in,
we're going to load in our own styles.
And we're going to put them below
Bootstrap, remember that CSS
is applied in the order that it
shows up, all things being equal.
So, if we want to have our
styles not be overwritten by
similar styles in Bootstrap, we're going
to put our styles last in this list.
So in our styles.css,
we're going to add a body selector.
So this will target the whole HTML body.
And what we're going to do then is,
if we go back to Google Fonts.
They'll actually have provided
how to integrate it into our CSS.
So it'll give us this font family and
we're going to put that
right into our CSS.
And that's going to say to the browser,
use this font if possible,
if not fall back to just a whatever
sans-serif font you have lying around.
So, now if we go back to our page and
refresh, there we go.
So now we're using that new font.
We're starting to look
a little bit better,
a little bit closer to our mock,
and we can go on from there.
One of the things looking at the mock is
that we have some other colors in here.
It looks like instead of being
sort of the dark gray or
black that is the default in Bootstrap,
our designer has given us a color for
all of the text on this page.
So we're going to go back.
We're going to add that
to the body as well.
Now, this is just the default color.
We can override it at any time,
but this is In general,
the text on our site we're
going to give this color.
And the other thing is that because I'm
loading in these two different weights,
the thin and the thick,
I'm going to make sure that my
style actually calls that out and
says as the default we're going to use
this slightly thick one, the 300 weight.
And so we'll put that right
back in this body tag, too.
So looking at our code here.
The colors have now changed to
the one we just set and we know for
sure we're using the right weight.
Looking at our mock, we have a few
other text sort of effects
that I'm seeing here.
One of them is this featured
work is in a muted color.
And one of them is that the Jane Doette
here at the very top, this title is
thinner than the other sort of
headings that we have on the page.
So let's write some rules
that will help us with that.
Bootstrap, as I mentioned before,
has a whole bunch of text helpers,
like text-uppercase, text-right,
those sorts of things.
So we're going to make our own and
we'll just add to that collection.
We'll make a text-muted.
And that'll change the color
of any text we put that onto,
be a little bit more muted,
a little gray.
We'll also make the text thin.
That'll use that thinner version of
the font that we've also loaded in.
Just making these classes isn't going to
change the way that the HTML looks,
that it displays on our page.
So now we have to go
back to the HTML and
add these classes in where we want them.
So I'm thinking we'll put the.
Text in on the name and let's find
that featured work, here we go.
All right.
So we reload our page here and
now you can see Jane Doette at his,
the thin text we were looking for and
featured work has turned grey.
So it's coming along here but
we still got a few more things to kind
of polish up and
we will start to work on.
One of them is that the logo here
seems to be off a little bit and
we'd like to give it
some room on the top.
And another is that, the name, this
JANE DOETTE, this title, this sort of
super title up here, is much bigger
than anything else on the page.
So we're going to try and
bump that up in size.
So again, in our HTML,
let's put in some classes so
that we can actually hook onto that with
our CSS and target the right things.
So one of the things we
wanted to target was that.
Jane Doette, that top heading there.
So we'll make this,
we'll give this like a title super so
this is the biggest title there is,
and it's at the top of the page and
the biggest thing we have.
And then we also wanted
to target that logo.
So let's call that, so
that things are similar, title logo.
So that's the logo that's
in that title space, and
this is the super text that's in that.
Okay, so now we have that in HTML,
let's go stick some CSS to it.
The general note, I generally
organize my CSS files when I'm
on smaller projects like this
in we'll do like the body first,
the very basic, the resets,
those sorts of things.
General classes,
classes that get used a lot and
then more specific classes
further down the file.
And for small things like this,
it works great.
And it'll let you know in your head,
sort of,
where to look in the file when
you're looking to change something.
So for that super title,
let's give it a,
crank it up to 60 pixels
to start with here.
And then we'll target the title logo.
Give it a bit of a margin and
push it down to there.
So now, when we refresh our page,
that Jane Doette is nice and
big, the logo is nice and in line,
we're starting to look a lot closer to
what we're going for in our mock here.
So as I'm looking at our mock,
I've actually noticed something that I
missed the first time and this happens.
You basically go through your design and
you're checking it side for
side with your mock or your image.
And you'll notice something
that you missed the first time.
It's an iterative process
as you do it more,
you'll miss fewer things
the first pass through.
But what I've noticed is
that I don't think that
my text at the bottom
of these is centered.
So I'll actually jump back in.
You can see down here in
the featured work section,
these are all left-aligned.
And actually,
as it turns out, everything in this
entire section here is text centered.
So what we can do is add that.
Remember, Bootstrap had that text-center
class, we can actually add that
to the parent of all of these,
and it'll apply to everything.
There we go.
So now everything is that
sort of centered text.
And we're starting to get closer and
closer to how our mock looks.
Now, I'm going to call it here for now,
because this has gone pretty long,
but you can keep going.
You can say, hey, this HR,
this horizontal rule here,
is not thick enough.
Hey there's not, it's not quite as
bold as I want it on these titles,
you can keep going and
keep going closer and
closer to the mock
that you're trying for.
At a certain point,
you'll just have to call it a day.
And that's okay, getting a Web page to
look exactly like the mock that was done
in PhotoShop or wherever it came
from is tremendously hard and
very time consuming for
the last couple percent.
so, getting to a good place and
saying hey, this looks good.
I feel good about this Web page,
I think people can use it.
If you're working with a designer,
getting their thoughts on that as well
is definitely a worthwhile activity.
And wrapping it up and saying,
okay, I think we're good here.
So, I'm going to leave this as it is for
right now, and I think we'll.
So, I'm going to do that right here and
say, hey, we're good enough for
right now.
If we wanted to do more work on it, we
absolutely could, but we've got a good
looking website here with a lot of
little puppies, and I'm a happy camper.
One of the things we get from using
Bootstrap is something like this,
where if we look at our website and
I've scaled my browser down to be
similar to a to a mobile device.
We actually get a nice layout.
All of our little featured work has
gone into a line here, it's readable.
And we can actually see
it on a mobile device.
Now we didn't do any work to make this
happen, which is really impressive and
we definitely can do a few more things
here to make this look better for
our mobile friends, but
it's a great starting place and
we didn't have to worry about it at all.